you're still looking for a christmas
gift maybe too late for online stuff but
we are checking in with lifestyle expert
sema cohen who's sharing some great
holiday gift ideas for everybody on your
list
hello las vegas now it's great to be
back and present
my holiday gift ideas for the whole
family
the holidays are coming up and all of us
are shopping for
everyone on our list here are some of my
topics
here we have the perfect gift idea this
holiday season
for all the kids in our lives and for
the busy parents
who need a great source of entertainment
for their holidays
we have silly poopies hide and seek
this is the first children's toy from
what
do you mean silly poopy is a plastic
rainbow
hide and seek toy who sings talks and
lights up
when you find it to play all you have to
do is just hide silly poopy
look for it and find it to hear the
special song
that makes you want to dance this is the
perfect
kids gift idea you can find them on
amazon
target and walmart all right
any health nuts out there i got you
covered
health aims to create clean and
effective nutrition
and personal care products that are
artificially
free organic and made in the u.s
the daily vitamin is the most complete
lineup
of 29 foods and vegetables in a
multivitamin
it's also non-gmo vegan and has
no synthetic fillers i love that the
pre-workout
natural energy supplement fantastic to
take before you work out
or if you know that you have a busy day
ahead it's made with
real strawberry lemonade no artificial
flavors or
ingredients last but not least skincare
they also carry skincare line
this is perfect because it helps you
make your skin looks useful
beautiful and the best part no harsh
chemicals
and it even has vitamins and nutrients
in it
you can find them on health brands.co
all right food is i got you covered
sadaf is the perfect gift idea for all
the foodies and cooks on our list
sadaf is a family-owned company that's
been around for over 30 years they take
pride in producing chef inspired kitchen
and pantry items
that are wholesome and as close to
homemade as possible
they carry unique kitchen and pantry
items that you absolutely can't find
anywhere else
the best part they ship nationwide here
is a gift idea that i absolutely love
it's full of mediterranean olives
spices gems and their famous avocado oil
if you go on the website you can
actually create your own unique
customized baskets great great idea for
foodies and chefs
all right last but not least black and
berry makes
toxic free sustainable product of the
highest
quality with beneficial ingredients they
strive to have
zero negative impact by using the most
pure organic ingredients and aluminum to
house them
black and berry living products are 100
organic
non-toxic and recyclable this is
perfect for everyone on your list who
cares about the environment
inside and outside of the home happy
holidays everyone